πέδευσην υπάρχουν συγκεκριμένα και διαφανει κριτηρια δεν μπορώ να πάω λεμεσόν να έπρεπε να πάω
πάφωνος πουμε κάποιος άλλος με περισσότερες μονάδες θα πάει στη λέμες αλλά συνέχειαν ο κόσμος
λειτουργει έτσι είχε μάθει φαίνεται δεν το ειχαζήσει στην προηγούμενη μουζωπρο την οριά γοθέσειναι θέλουμε
να πάρετε τούν την κοπέλλα νεδώ αντιεκείλεο υπάρχουν κανονισμί τάει μπορεί να μην εισε αριστός
σε αυτόν στόν οοποίος σου το λέει αλλά μια φορά δ φορές θα καταλάβει και
ο ίδιος ότε δεν μπορεί να περάσει μαζςεπειδήσαστα και αθλτριά τέλεα καιός παιδίας θέλει τιςκαι
αφλητισμού και νέολαία και νέολαας δίνεται εμθασιώτε πλένοντα σχολία να χουν και τις εγκαταστάσεις σε
διαφορά τα κλήματα ωστε μάθητες να μπορούν ναεργολούντε και γεμναστική να μην να μια ώρα
σες ελγά και ενείς είναι δύο ιστόχη μασ εδώ είναι καιο αθλητισμός για όλους δηλαδή
να δώσουμε ευκαιρίες σε όλα τα παιδιά αλάείνε και το άλλον οι έγκαιροι διάγνωση και
εντοπισμός στων τα λντον για να μπορούμε να έχουμε και τον πρωταθλητισμό αρα και τούτα
τα δύο μας αναγκάζουν να δούμεταις υποδομές σε συνεργασία με τον κόα στον οποίο δίνουμε
να σοβαρόν κονδίλινος κράτος έχουμε κάμει τού τη την προτεραιοποίηση και δουλεύουμε και με τις
τεχνικές μας υπηρεσίες όντους η δουλειά είναι τεράστια θέλει μια πε τα αιτεία για παράδειγμα
να μπορέσουν να διορθωθούν χωρί να βελτιωθούν να αναπτυχθούν οι αθλητικές εγκαταστάσεις για να μπορούμε
να μην τρεπόμαστε για κάποιες αβαυτές για να μπορούμε να λέεμε ότι τα παιδιά μαςμε
ασφάλεια να θλούνται είναι πολύ σημαντικό το θέμα τις ασφάλειες και κυρίως για να εκανοποιήσουμε
τούτους στους δύο στόχους για μέένα ο αθελειτισμός είναι η γιής απασχόληση που θα αφήσει
μακριά τα παιδιά από άλλου ίδους εθισμούς το ξέρω και από πρώτοχαίρι παρόλο μου είδα
πριν πάχπορολά χρόνια και τα δεδομένα ήταν πολύ διαφορετικά αλλά το βλέπω και σε παιδιά
τώρα τους βλέπεις να